I got to get your thoughts uh there was
a big fight that happened this past
weekend um what are your thoughts on the
uh the fury uh fight oh my God man did
he steal that one man I don't know what
I was watching I you watched it yeah I
seen some of it cuz I was sparring at
the same time got so now I got done and
I watched like the last four rounds but
I want to say I don't know I don't know
what I was watching like I don't know
what Tyson Fury was doing it didn't make
sense to me it didn't look like Tyson
Fury in the ring like it didn't but he
still won but cuz it was a was it a draw
it was a draw right but no it was he won
he won he okay okay but it didn't look
like him like I I watch plenty of Tyson
FY fights and uh usually he's punching
it didn't look like he was even throwing
punches he was doing a lot of hugging he
wasn't punching it didn't make sense to
me like it didn't he didn't look like
the same person to me I wonder like cuz
you always see like I I haven't seen so
many people say someone was robbed so
much in a long time like I remember
there was um maybe like a Pacquiao fight
like 10 or 15 years ago that I remember
it was there was a lot of back backlash
on uh when I was living in Vegas but it
seems like the consensus is that this
guy was robbed man any close fight they
going to say It's a Robbery yeah so it
don't matter like just because he's like
a MMA person and they they suspect Tyson
F to just wash him um if it's close of
course they gonna say It's a Robbery so
I don't I I ain't watched The First
beginning rounds to really tell you um
but I all I'm going say is I it just
seemed like they want that to be like
the narrative so well I mean look at the
end of the day like that that is
something that a lot of people say about
boxing is that they feel like because it
always goes to scorecards that it there
is room for people to get robbed you
know what I'm saying like and from a
Fan's perspective you know what I mean
I'm I'm sure it can be frustrating to be
like yo there some bad judges there's
some bad judges out there right and then
there's rematches that people want to
have made and all this [__] right so I I
don't mean to cut you off before you ask
your question but I want to say um any
MMA fighters who uh feel as though that
they could jump in a boxing ring with a
box anybody close to my weight I would
love for y'all to jump in the ring with
me and uh try me out caror McGregor try
me out any of them I don't care which
one it is uh um Cody Crawley what's the
people that's like there's the guy who's
like the Maga dude who's fighting this
weekend uh Cody kington yeah whatever
whatever whoever it is um that's close
to my way I would love for them to get
in R trop me out well it's crazy cuz the
nagana new dude like he like he held his
own like I was expecting him to get
smoked for sure and that's why I would
love to show like it ain't going to go
the same when I get in there I would
love to show like no MMA fighter could
get in the ring with me and even survive
have you had anybody approach you to do
anything like that cuz it seems like
that's kind of the the thing going right
now I heard it was somebody said that um
one of the guys said my name um what's
the guy he be going back and forth with
uh Devin too um I don't know his name I
don't know his name but uh like I said
any one of them dudes want to step in
the ring I it it feels like easy money
for you it is for sure but I just want
to show them like you can't jump in no
boxing ring
with me and it's going to go that way I
promise you I'm not going to lie to that
yeah I was a little surprised to see
that that fight went the way it went CU
yeah I ain't like it I was like damn
this going to open up the the the can of
worms for everybody to want to come I
felt like it it was
disrespectful um yo so this is the fight
that uh we're we're getting obviously uh
there's been a lot of I mean everybody's
asked you about obviously whenever
you're going to fight Haney is this
going to happen after this fight is
there any sort of progression in those
talks cuz I think we keep hearing about
the negotiations falling through maybe
he's not serious about fighting you what
what is is is that fight ever going to
get made I would love for the fight to
happen um [__] I y'all can clearly see
that I want the fight yeah like y'all
can clearly see I don't know why like
people try to spin the narratives and
like a lot of people good at social
media so they'll turn the narrative into
something else and 30 other people run
with that narrative but um truth be told
I love to fight like I I I fight anybody
yeah um I jumped in the ring with him
for a reason I didn't just jump in the
ring and do that for no other reason
besides okay let's get let's get the
fight started and and is the is what's
off about it still the split I think
what's off about it is his team like I
don't think I think his team is going to
throw anything out there to uh make sure
the fight don't happen um I don't think
that they want the fight to happen
happen right now um that's what I heard
like from what I was hearing I'm hearing
that well that's what it feels like
there's so many weird politics in boxing
that I don't think people understand if
you're just like a generic boxing fan
cuz you're like well this should be easy
like this guy and this guy they want to
fight this is a big money fight there's
a lot of money to be made but sometimes
like you said there's timing yeah it's
business and that's business above
everything and that's how they looking
at it they see it as okay why we fight
this big RIS fighter right now rather
than wait a couple of years we we could
make more money but yeah they could run
it cuz if they lose to you that's going
to [__] up that that might [__] up his
bag yeah and then like like like you
know it's it's almost like what happened
with um for people who are like casual
boxing fans it's like Jake Paul losing Y
is bad for business yes right so he has
to keep winning so the fact that he lost
to tyon or Tommy Fury is is is uh was
was kind of bad for business yeah but
like I say him and that one dude well
his brother and that one dude of they
they stirred up some [__] and that fight
was terrible my only issue with it right
yeah if that's the case don't perpetrate
as if you're that's what you want to do
you know you're perpetrating and acting
like that um this is what you want and
um you talking big but truth be told um
you put me and him in a in a ring where
nobody else can help him there's nobody
else that going to be able to fight for
him what's going to happen like he know
deep down inside that I'm the truth
that's what he know he know he done been
the ring with me several times um he go
ask him like really ask him and tell him
to be honest about me as a fighter um
you really hear how he talk and um
honestly I think he's a good fighter but
um I think that is levels